[Music]
as president biden lays out his
infrastructure plan in pittsburgh today
we
will take you to another town in the
rust belt that has seen jobs and
livelihoods come and go
manchester ohio is dealing with the loss
of two
coal-fired power plants and the way of
life that went along with them
correspondent mark meredith has the
story tonight
sitting adjacent to the ohio river the
town of manchester has
plenty of natural beauty but over the
years its downtown became an eyesore
hope that it will get back to where it
was when i was growing up teresa blyth
is manchester's mayor
her mission is to regenerate jobs and
revenue that nearly all vanished
after two nearby coal power plants shut
down we were completely funded by the
power plants and
what do you do when your entire budget
is
affected several manchester residents
recently sat down with fox news to
discuss the struggle towns like theirs
face
as coal plants nationwide either
downsize or die
i didn't realize the devastation that
would follow and not not even the next
six months it was the next year and the
next two years
manchester's plants closed during the
trump administration
it wasn't something he could fix but
more plants may vanish in the years
ahead
under president biden who campaigned on
pushing america away from coal
the future rests in renewable energy i
need to stay here
former plant worker joel hansen says
he's eager to look forward
not back i'm upset i lost my job yeah
still
but things happen for a reason you know
you move on
under the plan unveiled today president
biden wants to spend 40 billion on a
program to help dislocated workers learn
new skills
many in manchester say they're open to
the idea but much more interested in
what small businesses can offer
truly learning how to brand and learning
how to market
educating the people and and we're proud
and we're loud
manchester's leaders admit there is
still a lot of work to do
it's not the government that's supposed
to come in and fix fix everything
that's the people's job what they say
for their town and others like it
it's all about determination you have to
change your
your focus you can't give up hope in
manchester ohio mark meredith
fox news